today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
so we unfortunately have to have today
what is a very
a real but admittedly depressing
conversation
and it's really about the future of the
united states be it biden or
trump who wins in november and
i want to approach this from a slightly
different angle so let me let me sort of
set it up for you
the starting point is that in all
likelihood
more than 60 million americans are going
to vote for four more years of donald
trump
in november they're going to see they
will have seen
what we saw for the last three and a
half years and they're going to say
i'm going to vote for four more years of
that and
the important context here is that
certainly
depending on who wins the election
we are changing the direction of the
country in the sense that if donald
trump gets another four years that's one
direction if joe biden replaces donald
trump that's a completely different
direction
but i was having a conversation
yesterday with former producer lewis and
we were talking about sort of the
outlook for the country
and inevitably these discussions come up
about
you know if biden wins then this or if
the senate goes to democrats than that
or if trump then this other path goes
forward
and of course the november election
results are going to have
major consequences we've been looking at
policy differences over the last several
months
and when you look at tax policy
yesterday donald trump during his
press briefings saying that he would
actually be cutting the capital gains
tax whereas joe biden wants to tax
capital gains as ordinary income which
would be i mean these are really large
differences in policy
uh look at um green new deal
elements that joe biden is including in
his climate plan versus what donald
trump has done i mean just look at
almost any policy and you see that these
are very different trajectories but
there's a really big difference in terms
of
outcome versus the makeup of the country
and when it comes to
voting in all likelihood somewhere
between
60 million and 66 million people
are going to vote for donald trump and
maybe the range is a little bigger maybe
it's like at least 58 million and
probably no more than 68 million people
are going to vote for donald trump but
around 60 million people are going to
say
this is the guy i want so the point i'm
making
is that even if we set the country on a
different path in january
by electing joe biden in november if
donald trump
is indeed removed somewhere around half
of the voters
will have voted for donald trump and
this
is not trivial this has real
consequences day to day for you
and for me beyond what the president
does so
certainly if you think about climate
putting in biden instead of trump will
make a massive difference
but depending on where you live half of
the school committee you might be
involved in
will be made up of trump voters
police officers doctors accountants
the people that we are going to be
interacting with on a daily basis even
if joe biden ekes out a win over donald
trump from the standpoint of the
electoral college
these folks aren't going away and their
ideology doesn't get
changed or fixed because their candidate
loses the electoral college
and i don't know what the answer to that
is and we've talked before in these
segments about
trumpism doesn't end when donald trump
leaves office be it in january
or january of 2025. that's not just a
catchphrase
it's not trivial it's not unimportant
it's extraordinary really and how do we
start thinking about that
because it's such a bigger issue and you
know there's this phrase that's often
mentioned it's something like
uh trump didn't create racists but
they're just more comfortable out in
public right now
much along the same lines donald trump
did not create
anti-intellectualism or
pseudo-intellectualism we've done
interviews and i've explained to you
that those ideologies have been around
since
uh the 1800s in some form
approximating what we have today and uh
they have been
coalesced into um a sort of voting block
at this point we saw it with george w
bush and we see it even more with with
donald trump
and so this is a bigger picture issue
there's no doubt that
much more than george w bush donald
trump has
sort of coalesced and emboldened this
non-thinking crowd
but once the election's over and
hopefully trump leaves this january
it might not be until january of 2025 it
remains to be seen
what happens with that anti-intellectual
non-thinking trumpist ideology
that doesn't go away what happens in the
senate
what happens in the house of
representatives this is not trivial and
it's something that we really have to
think about and what
no matter who wins the presidency there
will be somewhere around
60 to 65 million people who say
what i saw the last three and a half
years i voted for more of it
hopefully they won't get it but we'll
still have to deal with those people
and that gets me to the next topic i
want to discuss with you today
which actually relates to the popular
vote sort of in this context so let's
talk about that next
in the immediate there is no better time
than now
to talk a little bit about uh the plans
for people who are voting in very blue
states
and in very red states who maybe you're
planning to vote third party
maybe you're planning not to vote at all
because the outcome in your state is
essentially determined now as
most of you probably know in the united
states we don't have a national popular
vote we have an electoral college so
if you win a state as a presidential
candidate by just
one vote you get all of that state's
electoral
votes and it has no impact on what
happens in other states
it's really 50 individual elections
because of that system that we have
really
the election is determined by a dozen or
so battleground states or swing states
as they're sometimes called so
these include places like wisconsin
north carolina ohio florida
etc and it's very common that people in
very blue or very red states who are on
the left
will say to me i get these phone calls i
hear from people in person
etc they'll say you know i live in utah
biden's not going to win
i might vote third party or i might not
vote or whatever
and then i'll hear from people in states
like my state of massachusetts who say
biden is winning by what is it at this
point 30 40. it's crazy what biden's
winning by
in massachusetts it doesn't really
require my vote to make sure biden gets
massachusetts electoral vote so i i
might vote
maybe i'll vote green party to give them
some support or whatever if there was
ever an election where that is not the
approach that we should have
it is this one if there was ever an
election where
every blue state and red state voter
needs to make sure that you are voting
for joe biden it is this one and you
probably can
guess why i'm going to make this point
there is a very real possibility
that donald trump will claim that the
election wasn't fair
that it was rigged that the results are
wrong
and in particular if it's very close
nationally or within the key states that
end up being the determining factors
we may have a situation where not only
do we not know the results on november
3rd i mean with the number of mail-in
ballots we're going to have it's
certainly reasonable and not a problem
for me
that maybe we don't know the results
until november 6th or 7th
7th i want the right results rather than
the fast results but put that aside for
a second
we could again end up with a situation
where the supreme court gets involved
here and some people
sent me a clip of sam cedar recently
talking about this saying
we might not know who won on tuesday and
trump will in all likelihood claim that
he won
lawsuits may start in a variety of
different states
and it could be a never-ending battle so
we need a
large margin in every single state
and also we want the largest possible
popular vote margin why well because if
it does get to either
secretaries of state or supreme court
justices the more overwhelming the
defeat is
of donald trump if we are going to get
one the more difficult it's going to be
for supreme court
justices to justify funny business we'll
leave it at that
which could end up handing the election
to donald trump there's no guarantee
as we know the supreme court is liable
to do anything at any time
but the point is winning the popular
vote by 3 million votes which is roughly
what hillary clinton did in 2016
while still seeing donald trump become
president with an electoral college
victory
that's just going to be too close and if
this extends a few days
into weeks because of lawsuits and on
and on into the supreme court
particularly while donald trump is
trying to kneecap the postal service
to try to prevent vote-by-mail absentee
ballots from being delivered we need to
do everything we can
to avoid small margins anywhere we want
to avoid small margins
in the states that will be close we want
to avoid small margins or smaller
margins than we could have in california
and massachusetts we need to run the
score up and if the election comes down
to a couple of states
and the popular vote is closer rather
than less close
it just better enables donald trump to
claim whatever the hell
he plans to claim if we overwhelm the
vote so much
that trump is crushed in the popular
vote the claims are just slightly harder
to make seriously
california has millions and millions of
democrats and joe biden's clearly going
to win who cares
go out and vote and run up the score in
california massachusetts will easily go
to joe biden
you'd better believe i'm going to be
voting and encouraging everybody i know
who votes in massachusetts to be voting
everybody has to vote because we have to
i i don't know of a better term than to
run
up the score and then and only then
if we succeed in removing donald trump
then we go back to what i discussed
earlier which is we will have to deal
with trumpism
and the 60 62 64 66 million
people who will have seen the last three
and a half years and will say yeah give
me another four years of that
following sam cedar's logic on this
which i think is sound
um it's possible that overwhelming
margins
could sway one supreme court justice you
don't have to
if it's going to be 5-4 in some decision
over some lawsuit that trump files
if it's going to be 5-4 an overwhelming
popular vote
victory swinging one of those nine votes
could make all the difference in who
ends up being president as of january
20th 2021
uh and voting is something we can all do
it's our right let's exercise it
august 23rd is the 15 year anniversary
of the david pakman show
we will have a huge membership special i
can't
say any more about it because it's
borderline illegal certainly immoral but
maybe even illegal in some states
be notified of this great membership
special by grabbing a membership
i'm sorry by getting on our newsletter
at davidpakman.com
you will then on august 23rd be notified
of how to take advantage of this great
membership discount the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
christine cedarstrand
and dale carter christine and dale thank
you so much for your support and also a
big thank you to michael o'brien
michael's been a member for almost five
years if you can believe that
and is today's longtime sustaining
member of the day
consider yourselves invited to grab a
membership at jointpakman.com
and you will get the daily bonus show
it's an extra show
every single day for our subscribers uh
very exciting join pacman.com and if you
want a discount don't feel obligated but
you can take it the coupon code this is
2020
because it is this is 2020 we'll save
you
40 percent yesterday's press briefing
with
donald trump was outrageous his mind
seemed to sort of turn to mush before
our very eyes with bizarre
claim after bizarre claim i'm going to
give you
very little lead up and just get right
into the clips i've gotten some
complaints recently david get to the
clips talk about them after
so let's just do it clip number one yeah
please jeff thank you sir i'd like to
ask you a question about something you
said in fedminster as well
he said that you're planning to issue an
executive order
to ensure that health insurance
companies prevent or
cover people with pre-existing
conditions and you said that
that had never been done before but
that's that's not the case because that
is
the law under the affordable care act so
my question is
why do you need to issue an executive
order for law that has already
existed but i didn't say i said as an
executive order i as you said
said as an executive order it hasn't
been done before we want to
uh we want to be able to assure people
that pre-existing condition is always
taken care of
this is truly one of the dumbest things
i've heard trump say
and jeff mason you might remember i just
dealt with this yesterday on the show
jeff
mason the reporter is spot on
pre-existing conditions
are already covered in the united states
they've been covered
for 10 years they must be covered by
health insurance companies you can't be
denied coverage because of pre-existing
conditions
because of obamacare we do not need an
executive order for something that's a
law
and trump comes up with this idea and as
you can see when he's pushed to come up
with stuff on the spot it doesn't go
well
trump says well i want to redouble it
because it's never been mandated
by executive order so we just want to be
like extra sure
this is absolutely ridiculous this is
like saying you know
murder is only illegal by law we've
never outlawed
murder by executive order we we sort of
need an executive order from a president
against murder because otherwise we only
have a law
against killing other people we don't
have an executive order
i have a hard time imagining a dumber
argument for why you would need an
executive order for something that's
already the law
tax fraud is only illegal by law
why hasn't trump passed an executive
order saying
we are not going to allow tax fraud in
the united states
it makes it's as dumb as it sounds okay
let's continue now on the topic of a
hundred and sixty thousand
american deaths uh due to coronavirus
if 160 000 people had died on president
obama's watch do you think you would
have called for his resignation
no i wouldn't have done that i think
it's uh
uh i think it's been amazing what we've
been able to do if we didn't close up
our country we would have had
one and a half or two million people
already did
we've called it right now we don't have
to close it we understand the disease
nobody understood it because
nobody's ever seen anything like this so
the question is a good one
if coronavirus hit when barack obama
was president and we had a hundred and
sixty thousand deaths
would you donald trump be calling for
the resignation of barack obama and
trump says no and of course
there's a tweet for everything there's
actually four or five tweets but just to
show you one
donald trump did call for barack obama's
resignation
because one guy with ebola got into the
united states through an american
airport
trump tweeted back in 2014 days before
the 2014 midterms and you might remember
that
the day after the 2014 midterms we never
heard another word about ebola because
it actually
was not uh an outbreak of any importance
in the united states
trump said if this doctor who so
recklessly flew into new york from west
africa has ebola
then obama should apologize to the
american people
and resign but resign over 160
000 dead no he would never call for that
because
why it's trump this time that's actually
the only difference
next again with 1917
listen closely to this one the closest
thing is
in 1917 they say right the the great
the great pandemic certainly was a
terrible thing where they lost
anywhere from 50 to 100 million people
probably ended the second world war all
the soldiers were sick
uh it was a that was a terrible
situation and
so again with the 1917 stuff now of
course the 1918 flu
was in 1918. we've interviewed uh
historians who are experts in the 1918
pandemic i asked in very clear and
simple terms
is there any logical reason you can
think of why donald trump would call it
the 1917 flu
no reason that we can think of but then
trump says
the 1917 flu which is really the 1918
flu probably ended world war
ii now you if you are even remotely
connected to time
and the fact that it moves forward as
far as we know
with our human understanding of it um
world war ii was decades
after the 1918 flu pandemic i can't make
any sense of it maybe he meant world war
one which would also be wrong but at
least it would be in the ballpark
in terms of the right decade trump asked
about
100 000 kids nearly 100
000 kids testing positive for
coronavirus
in the last two weeks of july that's a
very short period of time
and trump insists schools should open
and
yes he insists that children are
basically immune
on coronavirus 97 000 children
tested positive for coronavirus in the
last two weeks in july according to the
american academy of pediatrics does that
give you any pause
about schools reopening for in-person
learning
because they may have as you would call
it a case it may be a case but it's
also a case where there's a tiny it's a
tiny fraction
of death tiny fraction
and they get better very quickly
yeah they have they may have it for a
short period of time but that as you
know the
the seriousness of it in terms of what
it leads to is
is extraordinarily small very very much
less
than one percent believe that children
are essentially yeah i think that for
the most part they do
very well i mean they they don't get
very sick the truth is that every week
we learn more about kids actually being
very efficient carriers
of coronavirus now some get very sick
it's not that common that's true
but kids can be huge vectors of
spreading the disease and in fact there
was a
i don't know now if it was like a it
might have been a
some kind of christian summer camp but i
don't remember exactly somewhere in the
midwest
and they had a big outbreak and as they
tested the kids
the younger cohorts had more and more
coronavirus
so you know if you take like the 13 to
17 they had less than the 12 to you know
8 to 12
and then the really young kids had even
more so this appears to be completely
wrong
but the facts don't matter they really
don't matter
and unfortunately it's not just to trump
that they don't matter they don't matter
to his followers either
so now let's get to trump's new strategy
to try to say how great we're doing on
coronavirus i'm not going to tell you
what you're going to see here but see if
you can
spot the strategy including the short
term and the lab tests the lab tests
take a little bit longer
and dr burks was telling me a little
while ago that
we're down to two days and two and a
half days on getting your result on the
lab test the other ones you get them in
five minutes to 15 minutes so that's
exciting but countries in every
continent
are seeing increases in cases in recent
days
cases have rapidly increased in japan
and australia unfortunately
and they're now experiencing higher
peaks than they did in march
to the south of a border of our border
cases have continued to surge in mexico
central america argentina colombia peru
brazil
and throughout latin america it's really
the hot spot
it's posing a major challenge for
this continent latin america is now the
region with the
most number of confirmed cases by far
despite a
relative scarcity of testing so
trump mentions japan and australia japan
and australia are having second waves
so everybody's in trouble and the us
really isn't that bad off
there's actually a lot here to
understand so
first of all when you look at a country
like australia australia has as of this
morning
331 coronavirus deaths total
that number is maybe giving you a double
take could that really be true yes
total 331 australians have died from
coronavirus
we often have 500 deaths in one day
a thousand deaths in one day 1500 deaths
in one day
at the peak we had even more australia
does have a recent uptick in cases
but only up to a few hundred cases per
day
we have forty thousand cases a day sixty
thousand cases a day eighty thousand
cases a day
but the real difference is that
australia has immediately started
shutting back down and extending
guidelines
whereas in the united states when we
have 40 60 80 000 cases a day you get
people parroting talking points like we
have a lot of cases because we test so
much
and we certainly don't need to close
anything trump mentioned japan
very similar japan has a population of
125 million
that's about 35 of the population of the
united states okay
um they have a thousand deaths total
total okay
per capita japan's death rate
is dramatically lower than the united
states and
trump is right japan is seeing more
cases over the last 10 days
uh they have a fraction of the cases we
do per capita
and they are immediately expanding
guidelines and shutting things down so
comparing the us to australia and japan
first of all has to be done on a per
capita basis but most importantly
they are seeing cases go up and they are
shutting down because they are taking it
seriously we are not one little clip
here
about car companies check this out 12
million
or 12 million above expectations
which is pretty remarkable today we had
great
reports on new job openings and there's
clearly a housing boom which has been
incredible numbers in both housing
and an automobile boom we've rarely seen
anything like it and it's going on right
now in america
inventories are at rock bottom used car
sales are at record levels
and we will have rebuilt we're doing
a rebuilding like nobody's ever seen
it's a big plus for
manufacturing and construction so
construction's
getting close to record territory
manufacturing is doing very well the car
companies are doing great
very happy for michigan the state of
michigan we have a lot of car companies
moving in a lot of plants are being
built and expanded in michigan and
ohio now just about everything trump
says there is a lie
uh claiming everything is at a record
high constructions that are everything
everything is just doing better than
ever
but he makes the very specific claim
that car companies
are moving into michigan and ohio i
looked around i was able to find no
evidence of that
and you know there really aren't that
many automakers so when you make a claim
like
automakers are just moving into michigan
and ohio and opening stuff up it's
really easy to fact check because there
aren't that many
automakers quite frankly and again a
provable
lie here's one will where i'll introduce
a little bit more
trump got an actual policy question that
was not just
kind of rant about coronavirus for two
minutes and
um he just can't discuss policy in any
depth whatsoever he has nothing to say
this is a brazilian reporter check this
out brazil to focus his
efforts in uh eliminating ethanol
tariffs
in brazil you have to you can't yeah
ambassador in brazil to focus his
efforts to lower to eliminate
ethanol tariffs in brazil we haven't
really discussed that too much but
at some point we probably will be and we
don't want
people tariffing us and if they tariff
us although i must tell you have a very
good
relationship with the president
bolsonaro
he's great he's and i hear he's doing
well he's recovered from
having coveted having covet 19 as they
say
and that's great and send in my regards
i think that as far as brazil is
concerned if they do tariffs
we have to have an equalization of
tariffs and we
we are going to be presenting something
having to do with tariffs and fairness
and
tariffs because we have many countries
for many years that have been charging
us tariffs
he just mutters coronavirus bolsonaro
we have a good relationship covid 19 as
they say
say hello to him for me if they do
tariffs we do tariffs
no ability whatsoever to discuss
policy in detail and then here's the
last one
trump again with his predictions about
the future of coronavirus
and people should vote like they did in
world war one in
world war ii and your numbers will be
in 90 days or less your numbers will be
very good i think much better on the
coronavirus or the china virus
but it's something you have to look
about look at and and say this is just
crazy this just came out half a million
incorrect
ballot applications sent all over the
state of virginia
so before changing topic randomly there
trump says
in 90 days things will be good this is
the guy who was at march or april where
he said
15 cases are soon going to be zero he
has
no idea about any of this stuff nothing
he predicts
can or should be taken seriously and you
really saw during this press briefing
donald trump's mind becoming
mush there's there's just nothing there
there's no critical thinking there's no
analysis there's no connection to the
facts and
sadly as i mentioned earlier in the show
60 62 million 64 66
maybe 68 million americans are going to
vote for four more years if that doesn't
motivate you
to vote regardless of the state you live
in
there's probably nothing that will
motivate you to vote
we'll have more coverage of this on the
david pakman show
instagram which is at david pakman show
you can follow me there
as well at david pakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today nicholas carr who's the author of
several books on technology and culture
including the pulitzer prize finalists
the shallows what the
internet is doing to our brains uh so
great to have you on i really appreciate
your time
thanks very much david it's my pleasure
so to start with
um i think there's probably a lot of
people in my audience who generally have
the sense that
uh maybe over the last many years it's
become a little more difficult to do
sort of uh deeper deeper learning
focusing on one task for an extended
period of time
there's some vague notion that maybe
there's something about social media and
140 character posts that may be
sort of retraining our brain to some
extent but how do you
generally characterize the way that the
modern internet and and technology
have changed the way that that we mostly
do our thinking
i i think human beings
have trouble concentrating have trouble
screening out distractions
in general were very distractible
and you really do have to practice that
and train yourself to concentrate and
focus and i think what the
internet does in general and certainly
social media in particular
is it doesn't give us either the
opportunity or the encouragement
to train ourselves and
and uh uh practice skills of
attentiveness
because it just floods us with with
information information that's
interesting to us and grabs our
attention but in little chunks
and so my argument is that essentially
what we pay
to get this abundance of fast flowing
information is our ability to
concentrate we can't tap
into those deeper uh more attentive ways
of thinking
is there something that's adaptive from
an evolutionary standpoint
about being easily distracted in the
sense of
you're building a fire but there's a
thread off in the distance and so your
mind goes to that
shiny object or moving object or
something along those lines
i think i think that's exactly it you
know you can
you can understand how in the distant
past
in order to stay alive in order to
survive you needed to know everything
that was
going on around you particularly
anything new which might be a threat or
might be a
opportunity to eat or or whatever so our
the way our brains work is that we're
rewarded
with dopamine in other ways little
pleasure producing chemicals
to gather information and i think it's
exactly that that this is an
evolutionary instinct uh that
unfortunately we bring over into this
new digital environment where there's
no end to new bits of information to
grab
and briefly hold our attention one thing
i've read and heard from some folks
is the idea that there was a time in
human history not that long ago really
where there would be a big debate over
a fact because we did not have facts so
readily accessible on our phones
and that i mean this is a very sort of
utopian outlook now that the facts don't
need to be argued about we just find
them
we can devote more time thanks to the
internet and the ready availability of
facts to thinking about the implications
of those facts or the future of humanity
how we should interpret that information
or whatever the case may be
it feels intuitively like that's not
what's going on but what do you think
about that idea anyway
i think you know i think it does go on
sometimes oh really okay there are
there are good uses of the internet and
and not so good
there are a couple of problems with that
that we've learned
one is that actually
having a super abundance of information
available means
anybody can find support for any kind of
belief even though
even if it's totally wrong so the idea
that we'd all share this
base of facts turns out not to be right
human nature
gets in the way and then the other
problem with that is i think when you're
distracted all the time when you're
constantly taking in information
you don't have time in your own mind to
make connections and associations
between all the different pieces of
information around you
and it's those associations and
connections that are required
to give you the bigger context to fit
new information into and that broadens
your thinking deepens your thinking so
uh so yeah we can google all sorts of
stuff on our phones or on our computers
but we're losing our ability to fit new
information
into a bigger context and as a result
we're just kind of turning into i would
argue
information gatherers that don't
necessarily have an ability to
engage in a deeper conversation with one
another or in a deeper train of thought
within ourselves there's some
interesting articles i'm reminded of
about
this idea of the political hobbyist
which seems very much related to what
you're talking about which is
given so much free access to information
about what's taking place
in the world politically comments from
elected officials
a lot of of data so to speak
there's arguably a less effective
political activist that comes out of it
because they are
just consuming information sort of as
you're pointing out and not actually
taking that information and doing
something with it to
politic political differences aside try
to influence
sort of their community and their
surroundings is is that sort of the idea
of what you're saying when you talk
about
information overload which may not be
particularly useful
yeah that's that's definitely part of it
i mean what we know about
people is that if you give them an
unlimited amount of information they'll
go out
and cherry-pick the information that
reinforces their existing biases
whether those biases are based on fact
or or or
fantasy or fiction or whatever and so
what happens our hope
when we you know when we started out
with the net with the web
was that we'd have such a broad array of
information that people would
would go out and sample different
opinions different points of view
as you say become better able to hear
other
other people and influence them or be
influenced by them
but what we found is that that rarely
happens unfortunately what what
what does happen is we all go out in our
little bubbles
in in in gather the information that
supports our existing biases which ends
up making those biases even stronger
then we find a lot of people that share
those biases and in that
has a lot to do with the polarization uh
we see today politically and socially
and an inability to talk uh beyond
the group of people that that shares our
point of view
to use this sort of economic term
there's arguably also a diminishing
marginal utility to information
for decision making purposes in the
sense of you know if you're buying a car
as an example
that first information that you you
obtain
about you know you probably have a
budget right so the price of cars is
very important
do you need a two or four-door car or a
sedan or an suv
over time the additional information
seems to be less and less useful to
actually
getting to a decision right when you get
to what are the spark plugs what's the
the life of the of the led bulbs or
whatever
and maybe that's also an idea to
consider here
yeah i i think i think you're definitely
on to something and i hadn't really
considered that but
you know and what happens i i think then
is one of two things either you become
so obsessed by the details
that you kind of uh you
you spend all your time gathering more
and more less in
less valuable information and it
prevents you from actually
acting um because you you suffer
information paralysis
and then the other thing is the digger
the deeper you dig
if we're talking about political speech
the more
reasons you find to to
put other people at a distance the more
points
of difference you start to uncover even
if they're
trivial points they they loom large as
you gather they'll
uh keep gathering more and more
information without without necessarily
uh as i said fitting that information
and understanding that information as a
part of a
bigger broader context yeah that's
something i've thought of in thinking
about for example like the political
divisions within the left
where sure you have some on the left who
are
almost moderate republicans as an
example
and you have some on the left who are
truly socialists but
really there's probably you know pick a
number 85 90 i don't know what it would
be
but there's a lot of overlap about sort
of what the majority of those who
consider themselves on the mainstream
american political left would want
and yet when you look at the discourse
on places like twitter and others
it seems overwhelmingly focused on the
the relatively small differences
yeah in you know in some ways that's
nothing new people
people have been you know subdividing um
themselves even within even when they
share a broad understanding for a long
time but i do think
uh the internet accelerates or
exaggerates
that already common occurrence it it it
provides
not only all sorts of ways to find new
points of distinction
but to to find ever narrower groups that
share your precise
um interest in your in your precise
views and as soon as you
have that group formation then even
other groups who share a lot of your
views seem like
outsiders seem like the enemy and and i
do think that's part of
uh the fragmentation we see even within
uh within groups groups of people who
you would think
would focus on their points of agreement
to go back where we started about
the effects of the internet on our
brains and deep thinking etc
when i've interviewed i interviewed cal
newport previously and read some of his
books and he at least to some degree
believes that
these are issues of sort of training and
thinking of the brain like a muscle and
that if you condition the brain to you
know you really you close a room and you
just
read 30 straight minutes that you're
building up a muscle essentially and
that this helps to push back against the
instincts that may be pushed on us by
sort of the status quo of western
technology and the internet
is your take that the solution is a
systemic one that it's at the individual
level the absent one it has to be the
other or
what's your thought on that i certainly
think it's i certainly think at this
point
we've created a set of social norms and
social expectations
that that essentially tell us we should
always be online
always monitoring new information always
sending out or receiving messages
you get that from employers you get that
from schools you get that
certainly from your friends from your
relations
so i think it's a systemic issue at this
point and that doesn't
that doesn't mean there's not an
individual component and i think
cal newport's analogy to building you
know
building muscle is is the right one what
we know about neuroplasticity plasticity
these days the brain's malleability
is that you really do have to exercise
ways of thinking
if you want to retain them otherwise
they're going to weaken over time
and ultimately disappear and i think as
individuals for a long time now we've
been training ourselves
to gather information very very quickly
to to
pull in uh bits of data and lots of
overlapping forms and
we're getting good at that but we have
starved ourselves in effect or not
exercised the ability to pay attention
which is hard for us to do as
i said so i think i think if we want to
change
you certainly have to pay attention to
individual habits but we also have to
recognize that society
is sending these very powerful messages
that tell all of us
stay online uh gather as much
information as you can
and don't turn off the flow of
information
in in practice the more attentive or
contemplative
uh ways of thinking that that are
possible for your mind but are
don't come naturally to us we've been
speaking with nicholas carr and we're
going to go to a break on the podcast tv
and radio show you can find our full
conversation which will continue on the
youtube channel
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so president donald trump has come to
the realization that he
probably needs fraud in order to win
re-election
in november he needs to suppress the
vote in order to have a
solid shot at defeating joe biden and
his administration isn't even hiding it
anymore there's a new report which i
encourage you to read in politico
explaining that trump's aides trump
staffers the people around him
know this and they're now looking at any
way they can come up with to suppress
the vote
curb vote by mail disenfranchise as many
people as possible
when they are people that are likely to
vote for joe biden rather than donald
trump now
you might remember last week i told you
we shouldn't be that confident in joe
biden's lead and that's true
that hasn't changed if you look at polls
that have biden up nine
and you see that there's a margin of
error of three and a half
that means joe biden might only be up by
two hillary won
by two in 2016 in the popular vote and
still lost the electoral college that
analysis from last week is true
and in particular if anything changes
between now and november that helps
donald trump a slightly improved economy
we'll talk about
q3 gdp numbers which we will get
literally four days before the election
um we could see a one or two point swing
away from biden and towards trump and
trump gets re-elected so that's all true
but it is also clear that it's too
close for comfort and the report in
politico points out that there is a
complete and total commitment from the
trump campaign
to a strategy not of improving the
country not of improving the economy not
of dealing with coronavirus the strategy
is
essentially fraud to suppress the vote
so that the will of the people is not
accurately represented
this is not the type of fraud by the way
that they claim exists trump now has
spent
two three months i guess pushing the
idea
that there was in-person voter fraud
back in 2016
and in 2020 there will be vote by mail
fraud if more people vote by mail
remember trump has not accepted
the popular vote result of the 2016
election
which had him winning the presidency
trump
won electorally in 2016. he lost the
popular vote by millions of votes
he still has not accepted that and now
he insists if we increase
mail in voting in 2020 it will be a fake
fraudulent rigged election
the real there will be fraud but the
real fraud
is what trump is doing to suppress the
vote
the real fraud is what trump is doing to
prevent vote by mail
and to kneecap the post office and we're
already seen seeing
bins of mail overflowing in post offices
across the country
as postal workers are restricted in
being able to work overtime to get the
mail delivered if you want fraud
in the sense of someone preventing the
will of the people from being done
it's what donald trump and people around
him are doing and they have gone
fully masked off they're not even
pretending otherwise and when you
actually look at the full list of what
they're doing
it should be criminal now the if we want
to give trump a consequence it's
removing him in november right
what he's doing should be criminal but i
mean forget it right
that's not going to be uh the way it's
handled you've got a massive effort
in a bunch of states to file lawsuits to
change voting rules when it comes to
vote by mail and voting absentee that
includes
minneapolis minnesota rather
pennsylvania and nevada
aides are trying to figure out what
executive orders can trump
sign to just unilaterally curb
mail in voting through any possible
means
they're looking at how can they stop
mail-in ballots from being counted after
election day as many of you know
depending on state rules as long as the
postmark date
of the mail-in ballot is before the
election or no later than election day
it would still be counted and usually
mail within states doesn't take more
than a couple of days to be delivered
and those vote
ballots would be counted in the couple
of days after election day trump is
looking to limit that
and trump is also looking according to
aids speaking to politico
trump is looking at could he tell the
postal service
not to deliver certain ballots that
states send
out all of this is on the table now
here is the really important message a
bunch of experts
in voting have looked at everything that
they are
planning they've looked at all of these
ways in which donald trump could
suppress the vote
and they've come to the conclusion that
these techniques can only do so much
in other words if you slow down mail
delivery
okay you can delay it but if people vote
early enough
if you send in your absentee ballot
two three weeks before the election it's
going to get there before election day
even if trump slows down the postal
service to some degree
um a lot of this stuff is done at the
state and local level
so the takeaway is slowing down the mail
finding executive orders to hamper
delivery of mail-in ballot all of this
different stuff
it can only do so much and if we
overwhelm the vote
it's going to be more powerful than
anything trump can do
from what's been floated so far so yes
at the state and local level between now
and november we need to do everything we
can
to push governors and election officials
to run the election properly to not
allow these dirty tricks to actually
take hold
we need to do everything we can yes at
the federal level
we've got trump's postmaster general who
needs to continually be dragged before
uh house committees to testify and to be
put on the defensive about what he's
doing but he still might get away with
some of this stuff
but in the end the cumulative effect of
all of these techniques all of these
ideas
it can only do a little bit of
suppression if our turnout is
low it could hand the election to donald
trump
if our turnout is high it will not make
a difference
if we overwhelm the vote and that
includes
when you can safely vote in person doing
it when you can vote by mail
sending in your ballot two three four
weeks early meaning if it takes
an extra five days to be delivered it's
not going to be
a problem these techniques
cannot put trump back in the oval office
if
if if if we vote and that's the good
news now
we also can't ignore the foreign
meddling
piece and that's what i want to talk
about next i hope that
we're able to have this next
conversation as adults
and please watch the entire video
listen to the entire story before
commenting i'm begging you
i've actually i hate to admit this but
i've delayed talking about this for a
few days because i know that even
bringing it up
triggers some people off a cliff into a
rationality but at this point i would be
doing a disservice if i didn't talk
about this so i'm going to break it down
as simply as i can
russia is once again meddling in the
election
in order to help donald trump now
disclaimer
listen listen very very carefully here
this does not mean donald trump is
actively participating or coordinating
anything with vladimir putin
this does not mean that russia is
coordinating
with trump what this means is that
russia is doing what they do all over
the world
and what they've done for a very long
time and what the united states does
all over the world this is a really
important message here
i'm not alleging and i'm not alleging
anything it's the intelligence community
it is not being alleged that russia is
doing
anything special right now russia has a
long history dating back
decades really like a hundred years of
using
a series of tactics depending on the
situation to exert
influence on foreign elections now for
everybody let's go through some of the
responses people are going to send me
what about china and iran i'll talk
about china and iran in two minutes so
let's wait
uh what about the fact that the u.s also
meddles in elections you're right
but i'm not in the of course the u.s
medals in elections
that's not what this story is about this
is about our election being meddled
in if you are against trump
and you want the will of the people to
be heard and for it to be the will of
the people that determines the next
president
right now we are talking about russian
meddling to help trump
in the next three months that's the
topic of this story it doesn't mean
some other thing isn't a valid story
americans meddling in nicaragua decades
ago
is true interesting and important
historically
it's just not what this story is about
so don't distract with that
so what do we know russia is pushing
their standard disinformation campaigns
targeting joe biden they're spreading
disinformation to hurt joe biden
the american intelligence community has
been briefing elected
elected officials about this now for
some time russia is working to
help donald trump by attacking biden and
meanwhile
yeah china and iran are working to hurt
trump
this is not just russia but you can't
deny the russia peace
that's the important thing russia
prefers trump china
and iran prefer joe biden based on
everything we know right now
doesn't make anybody better or worse
it's simply what is taking place
right now the russian interference
is not merely about trump per se and
it's not even about trump
specifically it's about russia's bigger
plan to destabilize
western democracy anybody who thinks
russia's preferences are
specifically about trump as a person
you're mostly missing the big picture
russia plays a big picture game
the game is so discord in western
democracies
to make people within those countries
and around the world think
wow you know democracy doesn't seem to
be working so well
in these countries the more that western
democracies lose credibility
the better russia looks in comparison
that's the idea
making it a reality is another story now
in terms of their reactions to this
nationally
democrats and republicans are just not
the same on many issues
if you've been watching this program
listening to the podcast you know that i
point out
here's an issue on which there is very
little daylight between democrats and
republicans and when that's the case we
talk about it
on this issue since 2016
democrats have sought time after time to
stop
and prevent this type of meddling
republicans
have gotten in the way of trying to stop
this type of meddling mitch mcconnell
has gotten in the way
of dealing with this donald trump has
done nothing about it so
please understand there's not anything
conspiratorial here
powerful countries try to influence
elections around the world
assuming you agree that's true there's
no particular reason to doubt
russia having a preference and that
preference being donald trump
because it's coherent with their
geopolitical strategy dating back for
decades
the us does it you're right china does
it yes
iran does it absolutely and so does
russia there's no
reason that we should be particularly
skeptical of that
why would we deny it it doesn't make any
sense the claim
once again just as a reminder is not
that trump and putin are working
together right now
the claim is from the intelligence
committee that the u.s
election is just another one and russia
is interested in the outcome
china's interested in the outcome iran
is interested in the outcome they have
different
preferences russia's preference is for
trump to win
and russia's tactics are likely more
sophisticated than those employed by
china
and iran because russia has been doing
this for a very long time
don't be defensive in the sense that
accepting that
doesn't mean you have to accept anything
else you don't have to accept
anything that goes into speculation but
there are people that get
very defensive when this is brought up
and they start talking about red scares
and all sorts of wacky stuff
it just it's very straightforward
there's nothing unique here
let's identify it for what it is we have
a voicemail number
that number is 219 to david p here's an
interesting voicemail that came in this
morning
hi david this is jeffrey from quiz new
york again
you know i'm actually very nervous about
this election uh
do you what do you think the odds are
that he's gonna be disrupting some
matter or some form
of trump because we'll never get a
dictatorship now
democracy is dead it's terrified my
democracy is dead and i feel that my
granddaughter
who found nine months old is going to
grow up in a totally different country
than i did
nobody thanks for all your reporting in
the book they stay healthy
okay so but listen i get the frustration
we have a president
with dictatorial authoritarian
tendencies
and a sort of wish for that he's a
wannabe
um you are correct that many of the
democratic institutions of this country
are in crisis and they are in jeopardy
but to go further right now and to say
this is a dictatorship is is simply not
accurate i do think it's important
to be on the one hand warning people
about signs and symptoms but on the
other hand we don't want to be
hyperbolic but the frustration i'm with
you
we have an opportunity to do something
about it very soon let's actually do it
we've got a great bonus show planned for
you today we will talk about the
upcoming
rnc and dnc conventions and our plans
for coverage
we will talk about this maskless rally
of motorcyclists
in south dakota and much more get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming
members at joinpackman.com i'll see you
then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video